Sorry that you had to undergo the trauma
again.
Because I know many of you are aware and
I'm not going to address it.
I'm just going to mention in passing.
Uh as I
said, it's all it's like I'm a prophet.
Not because I'm a prophet cuz I know
people. I know they would.
Did I not say that they're going to do
more streams trying to defame me, but
it's not going to work?
That tactic doesn't work.
It doesn't work, dude.
The gaslighting doesn't work. The lies
doesn't work. And sadly, I don't watch
them. They watch me. How do I know they
watch me?
Because people were sending me clips.
People sent me clips.
Where they're playing me insulting
people. Now, I hope their people who
watch it get curious to go back to the
video and see everything context and
learn their faith. So, they can be
stronger Christians cuz they're going to
learn about their faith, be stronger
Christians and see that they're frauds.
Obviously, for them to find these clips,
they're watching me.
Now, for the record, the clips that I
upload of them
are sent to me.
Right?
Are you with me there?
They're sent to me.
I don't watch these guys.
God knows if I'm lying.
The clips are sent to me and I upload
them.
But they watch me. And then they tell me
that as they're playing me insulting
people, they laugh, too. They can't help
it. They can't control it.
So, let me set the record straight.
Yesterday, just to let you know, from
what I was told,
Ridvan lied through his teeth. He's a
liar. He is a son of Satan. He's a
slanderer. He's a liar.
Because I was told that he supposedly
said in private conversation, I told him
stuff about my ex-wife. He's a liar.
He's lying through his teeth. And when
he says that he was being nice to me,
he's lying.
Because after he got caught committing
adultery, we've never spoken.
Right?
It's a lie. So, I don't know why this
guy thinks he's going to get away with
lies. So, I just want to set the record
straight. We're going to get into the
meat of the matter by the Holy Spirit.
So, I've issued a challenge. Make it go
viral.
Guys, make it go viral. I've issued a
challenge. It's now time for David Wood
and him to debate me.
So, make this go viral.
All right? Make this go viral.
All right?
Hold on.
Please
make these posts go viral. Let me see
where we're at.
Yeah, you didn't watch my
post here, right here?
So, make this go viral, folks. I even
shared it on Apostate Prophets Twitter.
Call them out.
And I
call out his lies.
He wants to know about my ex-wife. Are
you fascinated
with my ex-wife? Why do you care about
my ex-wife? She's my ex-wife.
Why do you care what happened 20 years
ago?
We're concerned about your current
situation adultery. He doubled down on
the adultery. Guys, he doubled down.
He didn't deny it. So, make this post go
viral.
I'm issuing a challenge. I challenge
both of them to debate me.
And I have a series of questions for
Adnan because someone told me that has
nine questions for about for me about my
ex-wife.
And when he was trying to justify his
adultery, he said it's none of your
business. No, it's our business.
Especially when he asked questions about
my business, we're going to make it
our business especially
when you claim to be a Christian cuz
we're not Cain. We don't say am I my
brother's keeper? We are.
So, go to the post,
right? Go to the post.
Make it go viral. Go to their channels.
Go on their social media platforms. Do
you accept the debate? No strings
attached. So, here's my debate
challenge. I promise you it won't take
more than 10 minutes of God's money.
Here's my By the way,
I know this is going to sting because
the names I come up with these guys,
they're not going to be happy.
David Woodstein, aka Deborah Wood
Bosheth, an adulterous prophet. Don't
you love these names, guys?
Don't you love these names?
Adulterous prophet, p r o f i t, and
also spelled p r o p h e t.
And David Woodstein
and Deborah Wood Bosheth. Now, you got
to know your Bible to know the word
Bosheth.
Bosheth is used in the Bible.
If you know your Bible, you're going to
know what
I'm referring to.
If you know your Bible.
I have challenged them to this. Let me
read to you the part.
I'm challenging the two Zionist dogs to
debate me on the issue of what the Bible
Bible's teaching on the modern state of
Israel is,
what the Christian position should be.
Now, here. They can call my bluff. I'll
debate [clears throat] them on any
platform with any moderator, anywhere,
and anytime. Please go to their social
media platforms. Go to their live
streams saying, "Send in super chat. Are
you going to debate Sam? He wants both
of you."
>> [clears throat]
>> I will even go to their channels, let
them moderate as long as I get equal
time.
I'll also fly in to debate them in
person, face-to-face,
and use the savings I have due to the
great supporters of this ministry, and
God bless you, reward you. Remember, I'm
not a large ministry. I don't have many
people.
Pray if God wants me to do this, my
support stay steady to finish the race.
And if not,
you won't need me, brother.
Right?
Of this ministry pay for my own
expenses. They can use Israeli shekels
to pay for their expenses,
or just contact the Prime Minister of
Israel
to send more shekels their way. And I
think I do. This is why these guys are
obsessed with me.
They
hate to love me.
They fear me.
And that's why they watch me religiously
cuz they're learning their faith from
this ministry. Glory to you, Lord Jesus.
And that's why they know where to find
the clips.
They're scared of me, guys. I'm letting
you know. David Wood fears me
because he's on record saying he thinks
I'm one of the best Bible teachers on
the planet, the greatest apologist in
Islam. The fact that I'm not part of his
cult, and I won't justifies bullying and
cult tactics and manipulation. He fears
me, and out of that, he hates me.
A red font fears me. This is just facts,
guy. It's not ego. God destroy my pride
and arrogance. It's facts.
And they don't know what to do with me.
They can't refute me scripturally, so
they want to attack my character, but it
doesn't work.
It doesn't work, guys.
He said, "No, oh, I back down?"
Oh, I don't know that.
So, here.
Here's my challenge.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> Why do I want to debate them? They can
use Israeli shekels to pay for their
expenses,
or just contact the Prime Minister of
Israel to send more shekels their way.
The debate will show that Deborah
Woodsteen,
an apostate Christian, are sons of
Satan. They have shown they don't have
the fruits of now the Lord Jesus forgive
them forgive me save them in Jesus name
I beg Lord to save all of us.
But their fruits are nasty. There's
nothing about Christ anymore guys.
No biblical exegesis.
No defense of the core doctrines of the
Christian faith.
It's about Dawa scandal Dawa gang
ripping up the Quran and by the way is
this true?
Can you confirm is this true?
Lepanto and everyone.
Is it true that David Wood
posted or received a video of a woman
put
on the Quran?
And you're telling me he's the
Christian?
Can you guys confirm that fact check? I
was told a video
of a woman
putting
on her menstrual blood.
You're telling me
he doesn't want to work with me and I'm
the one who's sick?
You're telling me I'm the one who's
sick?
You're telling me this is Christ-like?
This is Christian behavior to brainwash
manipulate your cult your minions these
dogs who idolize you to get them to
Quran?
And you're giddy about it?
So what if they start doing that to the
Bible? Guys do you understand? When you
do this you're going to push people to
then desecrate the Bible. Is that what
you want?
Do you want them to desecrate the Bible?
And you're telling me I'm the one who's
sick and got mental issues. The guy is
a confessed sociopath a narcissistic
sociopath. But let me finish I don't
want to make it about him. I promise
you.
After this we're going to go into the
subject. I just need to clear up the
air. I come with facts and receipts and
challenges. Let them expose me.
Now, if Here, why am I doing it?
The debate will show that Deborah
Woodstien and apostate Christian are
sons of Satan who masquerade as servants
Christ to fleece the flock as they don't
have to find jobs and have to work for a
living. So, he can use his money to
commit adultery.
The debate will further show that they
do not know the Bible.
They do not know the Lord Jesus and are
biblically illiterate and educated.
Let's see who's the con artist, the
scam.
Let's see who really knows their faith.
Expose me.
I'm hoping that God will use me to
destroy the bully Woodstien's cult and
save them from Woodistan. You know, if
Pakistan, you have Woodistan. Minions
and dogs that salivate and idolize him
cuz we got sick
demonized people, psychologically
disturbed people who don't care about
Christ, they care about their idol.
May God save us from that. You're not my
followers. You're not Shamounians.
You're not.
You are not. May God save us from that.
Since a man who justifies platforming a
confessed adulterer is not a Christian
and does not care about Jesus Christ. He
doubled down yesterday, folks.
He doubled down yesterday.
Apostate prophet said it's none of your
business. Someone told me that he says
none of your business when trying to
defend and justify his adultery.
He didn't deny his adultery. He's
defending it. He's justifying it.
And Wood is now platforming an
adulterer.
And he doesn't care about Christ.
Now, if Deborah Woodstien chickens out
and decides to hide behind another
dress,
right?
Then I'll be happy to face off with
adulterous prophet Mono Emano. Since he
already debated this topic with Andrew
Wilson, there's no excuse to run and
hide behind the Wailing Wall.
But, I have a second debate challenge.
You guys can clip this, too, and send
it.
I have a second debate challenge.
Yeah, Deborah
>> [snorts]
>> Woodshef and Goldstein. All right.
A second debate challenge. That's why
they laugh at the clips. Is it ironic?
They're telling me they're playing my
clips and so and they couldn't stop
laughing and the people in the comment
section couldn't laugh stop laughing.
Forgive pray for me CW that God will
forgive me.
And have mercy on me. My second debate
challenge. Let me just get it out there.
Guys clip it, make it go viral.
I will personally pay for all their
expenses. I promise you.
Brethren, I don't have a large
base of people watch me or support.
These things I risk losing support and
if I do God's will be done. He doesn't
need me and I will endure by the power
of the Holy Spirit and finish the race,
provide for my daughters.
But I will take the money I have saved
for my daughters. I promise you. Call my
bluff.
They'll understand. It's for a noble
cause. I'll pay for all their expenses
so they can save their shackles for
adulterous prophets honeypot
so they can fly to Israel, also to the
largest Jewish community in America
and preach the gospel of the Lord Jesus
Christ to the Jews both outside their
synagogues and by the Wailing Wall
where adulterous prophet hit his cross.
Remember I showed you that video? I'll
show it again if you want. And where
Yamaka as he went and touched like a
good little
If they can go out side of mosques
Okay?
And they can film
their
outreach to Muslims outside of mosques
and their debates. Why don't you see
Deborah Goldstein Goldstein
and adulterous prophet doing the same?
Why don't you have any video of them
when they were in Israel
preaching the gospel of Jesus Christ at
the Wailing Wall?
Why don't you have any videos of it?
Can they point to you
any time they were there preaching the
gospel of the Lord Jesus Christ in
Israel?
Anytime?
So, I'll pay. I want them to be men of
integrity. Tell me that they hate
rabbinic Judaism, the Talmud, as much as
they hate Islam and the Quran.
But, I'm going to play a clip and then
we're going to get into the topic.
And we're going to end it right here.
Look.
Yeah, Shamoun.
Do you condemn the Talmud and support
Zionism? Do I condemn the Talmud and
support Zionism?
What?
I don't condemn the Talmud.
I would condemn something inside the
Talmud.
Now, notice
Deborah Goldstein Weinstein
rips the Quran again.
I will not condemn the Talmud.
I may condemn something in the Talmud,
but why would I condemn the Talmud,
Jared?
Listen to it again.
But, why would I condemn the Talmud? Why
would I condemn the Talmud?
I don't think you know what the Talmud
is,
uh child of God. Jesus said Yeah,
Shamoun. Okay, hold on.
Let's follow the logic.
Why would I condemn the Talmud?
I may condemn something in the Talmud,
but why would I condemn the Talmud? And
he laughs.
Exactly, Lepanto. You're a genius,
brother.
But, hold on.
Why do you condemn the Quran? And here's
what's ironic. As he's saying, why would
I I the Talmud?
David Wood,
the sociopath, narcissistic cult leader,
or I should say Deborah Woodstein
Woodstein,
is ripping the Quran. But wait,
by that logic, why do you condemn the
Quran?
Why not just condemn things in the Quran
but not the Quran? Because after all,
let's be fair, right?
Let's be fair and we're going to be
good, I promise you.
Does the Quran say Jesus' mother is
No, the Talmud does.
Does the Quran say that Jesus' mother
Mary
got
a Roman Pandera?
No,
the Talmud does. Does the Quran say that
Jesus was a blasphemer who was pushed
away by his rabbi,
who learned sorcery in Egypt,
and manipulated people by sorcery?
Does the Quran say that? No, the Talmud
does.
Does the Quran say that Jesus is
No,
the Quran does.
Does the Talmud say Mary is the greatest
woman God created? No, the Quran does.
Chapter 3 verse 42.
Right?
If I made a mistake, let me repeat it
again.
I thought I said, yeah. Does the Quran
say that Jesus
No, the Talmud does.
The Talmud.
Just wanted to make sure I didn't make a
mistake.
Right? But does the Talmud say that Mary
is the greatest woman God created? No,
the Quran does.
Does the Talmud say Mary gave birth
supernaturally as a virgin to Jesus and
remained a virgin?
Does the Talmud say that? No, the Quran
does.
Does the Talmud say Jesus is the
Messiah, the word of God sent to Mary, a
spirit from him?
Does the Talmud say that? No, the Quran
does.
Does the Quran say, sorry, the Talmud,
Lord save me from error,
does the Talmud say Jesus raised the
dead, gave sight sight to the blind,
cleansed lepers,
>> [clears throat]
>> informed people of what they
store in their houses,
created a bird from clay, blew breath
into the bird, made it alive, the way
God created Adam?
Does the Talmud say that? No, the Quran
does.
Does the Talmud say that Jesus was taken
to be with God, where he remains? No,
the Quran does. Does the Talmud say
Jesus returned physically to judge the
world? No, the Quran does.
So, if we're going by not condemning the
Talmud, but something in the Talmud, the
Quran has more praiseworthy things to
say about Esau, whom we don't accept as
real Jesus, but nonetheless is supposed
to be Jesus,
than the Talmud ever says about Jesus.
So, why do you wholesale condemn the
Quran, not only parts of the Quran?
Are you with me there?
You with me there?
So, you see these
these cowards, they have sold their
souls
to their masters. Now, don't get me
wrong.
To me, the Quran, Talmud are evil.
Muhammad is a
and Antichrist. All of the Quran is not
the true God,
but neither is the God of rabbinic
Judaism, and the Talmud is more than me
and its treatment of Jesus than the
Quran could ever be.
I have not changed, and I won't change.
I'm not becoming like Tucker Carlson or
Candace Owens, God forbid. May the Lord
rein me in and getting soft on Islam.
Right?
But, my point is
why won't he condemn the Talmud? If
you're only condemning parts of the
Talmud or something in the Talmud, why
don't you do that to the Quran? In fact,
I'm going to issue another challenge. I
will pay
from my savings account for my daughters
that Deborah
Wood Busheth, aka David Woodstein
Woodsteen, an adulterous prophet start
tearing up those sections of the Talmud
that say Jesus' mother is a
I'm going to make another post
challenging them.
You got You with me?